madame fleury cours accueillent
actuellement de personnes handicapées à
son domicile à saint-andré l'accueil
familial est une solution intermédiaire
entre le maintien à domicile et
l'hébergement en établissement
un mode d'accueil qui permet aux
personnes qui ne souhaitent aucune ne
peuvent plus vivre seul de bénéficier
d'un cadre de vie familiale et de mettre
fin à l' isolement
ce dispositif constitue une priorité du
conseil départemental dans sa politique
en faveur des personnes handicapées
pour madame furie cours devenir
accueillant familial s'est présentée à
elle comme une évidence
mwami pense pour devenir une famille
d'accueil c'est le côté humain
naturellement donc la communication bas
tout au fait qu'on devait y déroulent
tous les jours naturellement parce que
moi tu peux me fais avec mes accueilli
ben me calcule pas deux mais c'est tous
les jours il vient naturellement le
contact et puis comme maman aime bien
beau métier donc pas moi qui fais ce
métier encore mon travail me tient qu'à
lisbonne dont d'avocats yele consisté
vin qui fait déroule de la journée donc
simon pas un pique nique le matin à
québec en petit déjeuner dans le midi
donc ce que tu manges après la sieste
15h café a qu'un petit bateau et le
goûter et le soir le dîner
le conseil départemental participe à
l'aménagement et à l'accessibilité du
domicile
la collectivité met également en place
des formations initiales et continues à
destination des accueillants familiaux à
l'effet travaux parce que fallait
fédérant pour les fauteuils handicapé
pour les personnes en fauteuil et des
plans inclinés de haut niveau que parce
que la bd démarche escaliers pas les
supprimer et les barrières de sécurité
aussi oui voilà
de toute façon pas fait pour avoir mon
agrément fallait que me fait les travaux
dans les nomme un véritable
environnement familial synonyme de
partage et de solidarité
les accueillit participent à la vie et
aux activités de la famille
voilà sa fille donc voilà où sont les
racines il se place donc variétale
matane camp de transit de jeunes et a
pris les armes et passez donc et après
de la plus mythique que cette activité
mais n'arrive une de nos minots mikado
donc voilà et après mais que monsieur
volée lui aime bien regarder la télé
j'ai monsieur klein ici donc voila apres
m y arriver au mans qui nous disent plus
enchaîné par exemple puis avril à
issoire l'industrie de juin
voilà le programme apprécié la journée
ça fait un an et demi national paulo ça
se passe bien que ça va mais la marge a
atteint 106 java blackberry race mâle a
fait savoir récemment andré guyaux
victime soit sa voix magique robidas
famille humaine sanglots mais l'exemple
toujours l'esprit made in bavaria mains
en bas de la paille est sur la paille
devant un pas devant paul bailly le
matin on y parle valley le tram à la
pension comme l'était avant de le moment
rien vu
j'aime mieux être accueillant familial
est un vrai métier où sont requises de
nombreuses qualités telles que la
patience l'écouté le dialogue et la
tolérance